grab your lederhosen sift through your
closet and find it because oktoberfest
it's back in las vegas you got yours i i
have like at least three pairs i gotta
pick out which one fits the mood
the two-story beer garden at ellis
island is offering the full bavarian
experience
candace charles joining us in her vest
this morning
i believe unlimited beer is an option
okay candace we're listening
i i thought i'd get you just with that i
mean the outfit helps too and i promise
guys this was not in my closet although
maybe it should be i don't know we'll
see but we're going to talk about food
first before we get to beer because you
got to eat before you know you drink all
the beer of course i'm joined by
christina ellis the general manager and
the lady behind this grand plan grand
barbarian plan right
now i know you guys got a few different
items on the menu and with the ticket
you can get the entree and an appetizer
so first we're going to look at the
pretzels here of course i'm going to try
it for you guys because i got you
covered but what other items are on the
menu absolutely so we have for entree a
pretzel or a uh some broc bites so you
know what's october best about some
bratwurst right exactly you gotta have
the sausage you get to go now have you
tried it yourself do you like it oh my
gosh it's so good all of the food here
at the front yard i mean it it can't be
beat and it's all food that pairs so
well with all of our ellis island beer
speaking of which we hear that there is
unlimited beer how does that work and
what kind of beers are we talking about
so we serve 12 beers out here in the
front yard so we have you know your
classic your light amber stout ipas and
then more creative beers so like a roush
beer which is like kind of smoky of
course our oktoberfest beer because you
know tis the season right uh and a
variety of different light and dark
beers but you have 12 beers to choose
from and for the three hour block of the
event so from five to eight you'll have
unlimited ellis island beer awesome well
we're gonna try some of this beer for
you a little bit later thank you
christina let's actually take a taste of
this if we can we got another time for
that thank you
also because i'm hungry guys as i am in
the morning dip the cheese yes
cheersies cheers
um
i like chocolate in my mouth full
it's a skill
is delicious
you can try all of this and more
on saturday september 24th
social media
from five days i'm taking my 65 bucks
you guys 65 bucks you get the entree you
can get the appetizer then unlimited
drinks you can dress up in the costume
maybe win the contest i'm going to try a
little bit later
you guys
can just breathe first of all first of
all breathe after you eat the pretzels
so many layers to this the ensemble the
eating and able to you know complete a
full sentence it's
it's impressive thank you
how'd it taste is it right is it good
it's good it's definitely good the
cheese is good i'm a cheese person and i
will tell you if the cheese was bad i
like to have cheese in my pocket if i
could but i can't so this is a good
substitute
cheese in your bed not hot sauce where's
canada she's got that trail of cheese
behind her her bag oh she's walking
through the newsroom
this morning bye candace